F3: . So we heard from Joe Biden yesterday
he's not for abolishing the filibuster,
but he wants to modify it and
require an actual talking filibuster.
On the other side of this is now Senate Minority
Leader Mitch McConnell, Republican from Kentucky,
and he is now very strongly threatening to
obstruct everything Democrats want to do
unless he is allowed to continue obstructing in
the way that he has been able to do. I know that
that sounds crazy, but what you have to understand
is Mitch McConnell is going to obstruct either
way. Mitch McConnell is now warning Democrats
that if they try to mess with the filibuster,
he will use procedural delays to turn the Senate
into a, quote, 100 car pileup, saying, quote,
Nobody serving in this chamber can even begin
to imagine what a complete scorched earth Senate
would look like. I want our colleagues to imagine
a world where every single task, every one of them
requires a physical quorum, which, by the way,
the vice president does not count in determining
a quorum. And many Democrats are realizing he's
already been just obstructing at every opportunity
for years. Dick Durbin saying he's already done
that. He's proven that he can do it and that they
will do it again. I assume Mitch McConnell has to
be ignored. Now, I'm not denying for a second that
certainly Mitch McConnell, if Democrats either try
to abolish the filibuster, which it doesn't seem
like they're going to do, or modify it, requiring
a talking filibuster, reversing the onus on 40,
60, as I talked about earlier, whatever they try
to do, I have no doubt Mitch McConnell will do and
will be able to do certain things to obstruct. But
Mitch McConnell has been doing that anyway. Mitch
McConnell is like an arsonist threatening to burn
down your house when he already burned it down a
week ago and you're already living somewhere else.
And Mitch McConnell, in the past, when Harry Reid,
10 years ago, he forced Harry Reid to have to go
nuclear to get anything done, and he obstructed
with the Merrick Garland selection by Barack Obama
at the end of Barack Obama's term, saying we don't
do Supreme Court picks in the last year of a term.
And then he rushed Amy CONI Barrett through in two
weeks. He will obstruct when it's convenient at
any time. He has no morals. He has no principles.
He will take whatever steps he wants and thinks
will be beneficial to Republicans at the time,
and then he will rationalize it regardless of
double standard, regardless of consistency.
I don't think Democrats have any choice but
to ignore him. And what I mean by that is
if you do nothing, then they obstruct as a
matter of procedure. If you do something, then
they retaliate by obstructing his painting. This
health scape, his talking points memo defines it
that as soon as they take back the majority, they
go back to running everything through and ignoring
Democrats. How long are Democrats going to pay
attention to the threats from Mitch McConnell? And
as propagandized and weaponized as the ignorance
is on the Republican side right now, I do believe
that it will start to have some consequences if
Mitch McConnell does what he's threatening to
do. So what Democrats should do is just listen if
they're not going to blow up the filibuster. And I
understand the risks to doing so. I get it. I it's
not clear to me that it's the right path. At least
agree on what reforms you want. Maybe you change
it to require a talking filibuster. Maybe you
change it to require 40 Republicans in the chamber
to extend debate rather than just an absence of
60 being enough to extend debate. You figure out
what you're going to do and then you just do it.
And you allow Mitch McConnell to deal with
the consequences of continuing to obstruct.
Many Republicans won't care. I get that. But I
believe that some will. And combined with centrist
independents and. Democrats and leftists, I think
it will be enough to damage the Republican Party,
that's my view. Now, if you disagree with
me, if you think it will have no consequences
and you actually have to listen to Mitch McConnell
here and take the threat seriously in terms
of how it would affect what Democrats do on the
filibuster, let me know. I want to hear from you.
I'm on Twitter at David Pakman. And then reminder,
Friday, not this Friday, next Friday, March 26th,
we are running an end of March one day membership
special. It is going to be a huge discount.
It's because we had a really rough February, the
virus, the pandemic affecting people financially.
I got dozens and dozens of emails from
people saying, David, I love the show.
Been a member for years. I've got to cut every
bell whistle and extra from my budget. I get that.
So we're going to offer a really big discount on
March 26th. I would love for you to sign up if
you're interested. It's almost like registering
for the vaccine. Actually, get on my newsletter
at David Pakman Dotcom. And then Friday you'll
get an email telling you exactly how to sign up.